a few months ago I took a road trip from
Chicago down to New Orleans and on the
way back out we were somewhere either in
Tennessee or Missouri I got pulled over
it's my first time getting pulled over
and it wasn't for speeding it was
because I was driving in the left lane
so there are basically two types of
drivers at the world there are people
who get really upset about all the
people driving slowly in the left lane
that's Joey he fits in the first group
and then there are a lot of drivers who
have no idea that this is even a problem
yeah that was me sorry about that
I don't drive much the truth is when
drivers hang out on the left lane it
makes traffic worse and more dangerous
for everybody involved here's what that
looks like if you have relatively slow
drivers scattered amongst the right and
left lanes
faster drivers have to repeatedly slow
down and weave back and forth changing
lanes many times to pass all of them so
if you're going five miles slower than
everyone else and you're traveling the
left lane it forces them to make
dangerous moves trying to pass you on
the right which is more likely to cause
an accident but there's a better way for
traffic to flow and that's if we only
use the left lane for passing if all the
slower drivers are in the right lane a
faster driver can pass several at once
then get back over to the right which
cuts down to the total number of lane
changes and eliminates the slow down
move over or get a ticket that's the
message from state troopers to people
driving too slowly in the left lane some
people argue that as long as they're
going the speed limit
they shouldn't have to move over but
there's evidence that slowing down and
changing lanes is actually more
dangerous than speeding research has
shown that the strongest predictor of an
accident is variance from the average
speed of traffic and a car going 5 miles
per hour slower than the surrounding
traffic has a greater chance of causing
an accident than one going five miles
per hour faster that's why every state
has some law on record that restricts
the use of the left lane in 29 states
any car that's moving slower than the
surrounding speed of traffic should be
in the right lane and in 11 states the
laws are stricter they say that the left
lane is only for turning or passing
historically police didn't really pay
that much attention to slow left lane
drivers but more recently there have
been
campaigns in places like Washington
Texas and Ohio where police are actually
issuing tickets to people they spot
traveling slowly in the left lane the
reason why I stopped you is the law in
the state of Washington is keeper ID
accept the pass
this is something that has always been
illegal and against a lot here in
Michigan but now officers are rolling
out this new education effort to help
the public understand just what they can
and they cannot do when it comes to this
type of driving now it doesn't have to
be this way a good example of this is
the German Autobahn so this is Germany's
highway network which has long stretches
of road with no speed limits and it has
surprisingly low accident rates one
reason for this some researchers think
is that German drivers are more likely
to stay in the right lane for traveling
and only use the left for passing if
that shared norm helps keep them safe so
fellow drivers I am sorry I didn't know
the rules but I'm not alone and if more
people understand how this works we will
have much fewer traffic jams and our
roads will be a lot safer too
you